I consider myself in New Yorker i was
born in the in the great state of new
jersey at perth amboy general hospitals
but got out of Highland Park New Jersey
to go to boarding school at age 12 I
knew there was a bigger and better way a
lot of us from New Jersey have a complex
about being from New Jersey but I have
rid myself of that complex because we
all have to come from somewhere and
sometimes our somewheres maybe seem like
nowhere but that nowhere gets us to
somewhere and it makes us be better so
I'm proud to be a Jersey boy but you're
making an assumption that jersey
symbolizes something and I don't know
what that assumption is let's just say
that I wanted to make things and be
something and try to create things and
where I came from had nothing to do with
stopping or starting me I just wanted to
do something as driven home by my
parents